tout ça est rentré dans l'ordre pour
terminer le premier grand événement
chorégraphique consacré au bicentenaire
de la révolution à paris au grand palais
un événement signé béjart à partir de
mardi et intitulée tout un programme
1789 et nous patrick jacq
béjart est à paris déjà répète et c'est
ce vaisseau rococo de fer et de verre
qui l'a investi avec sa compagnie pour
1789 et nous sa nouvelle création
millésime 1989 dédié noblesse oblige à
la révolution française
et cette fois-ci maurice béjart frappe
très fort par le lieu tout d'abord
l'ampleur du spectacle ensuite deux
heures sans entracte et le thème bien
entendu n'est pas question pour maurice
béjart de simplement souffler sur y at
il tant que la révolution qu'il faut pas
célébrer l anniversaire il faut la faire
tous les jours chaque matin j'approche
le vêtement évolution chaque jour et il
faut bien voir que il y a tellement de
choses tellement d'injustices tellement
de problèmes tellement de drame à notre
époque qu'il faut être vigilant quand il
faut pas s'endormir en disant bon bain
de sang en 200 ans bravo c'est la fête à
donner
conçue contre elle le monde change il
doit changer encore écrivait robespierre
longue déjà on a fait sans aucun doute
sa devise la révolution si elle a
aujourd'hui 200 bougies reste toujours
d'actualité
tous les soirs 4000 spectateurs ou ont
ainsi découvrir sur des musiques de
beethoven et d'hugues le bars
la vision très personnelle de cette
révolution tout sauf une reconstitution
de la convocation des états généraux de
la prise de la bastille de la nuit du 4
août ou encore du retour de voix à paris
fait de nouvelles bref on forte dans
l'instant les pages de l'arrêt ont reçu
leur congé pour le 1er janvier prochain
un peu un livre d'histoire magique
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui raconter aux
enfants mais aussi pour les mains
tout à fait porter à miner nous aurions
bien voulu vous montrer quelques images
du match de football france yougoslavie
mais apparemment le match touche à sa
fin mais il n'est pas encore terminé ce
match qui compte pour les éliminatoires
de la coupe du